yeah yeah let's try to see how it foams
up so just uh yeah yeah hi I'm Nick
Brooks hi I'm Dean Norma Jean II and
today I'm gonna teach my son how to
shave I say we have a good relationship
it's my dad he had me he's my only son
so you know there's a lot of weight on
his shoulders I feel good I think we
have a perfect relationship we get along
fine like the best friends you'd like to
play video games watch movies we go
walking every Friday and right he like
trails and hikes and stuff I'll try to
get in the shape you try keep my weight
down I would say I look up to him he's a
great teacher
he's always taught me how to save money
and I feel pretty good about that
that man lesson that one got through we
have conversation and and he learned it
say something insightful on my own
though I mean obviously has way more
experience than me life experience so
just hearing him talk you know I kind of
just get gyms that way too
yeah shaving is his is there's a big
deal for us like this video is his
beards a little different than mine is
facially is a little different than mine
but he's he's done pretty good
I learned the shape for my granddad so I
watched him do the whole school you know
it's so big brush I usually use a
clipper because of like the texture of
my hair it's a little curly and usually
when I save I use clippers cuz uh I try
to use a razor maybe like as a team you
know you're a teenager and you like a
candy dude how to say if you were to
start using a reason of course you break
out and then I just never use the razor
again since I was in like high school so
it'd be interesting you know I'm
interested to see how it how would take
I'm a little nervous but I don't think
it's that scary it's just shaving it's
not like a BASE jumping okay so we're
gonna get started you ready right yeah
okay use this first okay okay just
soften your hair so it'll lay down a
little bit okay I mean you can rub it
together I think you might need more
than that you sure got a small chain all
right ladies you're here now
yeah just a super oily yeah I mean you
got a dry it just you know we got the
shaving cream okay I'll have to use a
shave cream you can do but yeah I don't
think it's gonna hurt just like you're
not it's not you know how to work this
into your skin let me try first Yeah
right yeah that might help
hey yeah you don't wanna sit you don't
want it sitting on the top and do both
sides real good if you need more shaving
cream you know I should pull my hair
back I think you do it better honestly
like nothing like like I'm lazy but I
kind of want you to do it can actually
can do it better and drop a lot of water
you show me pretty lathered right yeah
okay you ain't trying to be the Joker
ready that's ready does I'm gonna be
this is a razor so what you need to do
if you can see the blade you're gonna
have to hold it at an angle
cuz it's different from like the threes
and the 5 whatever this is classic and
you'll feel it cutting so just take your
time yeah and then we're gonna rinse it
off a little bit and that wasn't so bad
man ain't a cold
you take these rains yeah
and just figure the movies yeah in the
cinema right and you know what I did
when it first do you feel a cut I can
hear it yeah but you see them saying
whoa hey just smooth straight strokes
man just be able instant you can be more
vigorous like let's keep contact with
your skin
I'm having too much fun you want to feel
the razor it's actually doing something
I'm supposed to do Sir Robin they're
over your skin yeah I know I feel it
it's just like really smooth really
smooth that's a good thing
are you you show me you really gotta get
that perfect angle I'm getting the hang
of it already yeah it's pretty smart all
right keep going there we go yeah face
under there about time just cut myself
you cut yourself no I got a weird shape
chin - so it's like you gotta really put
my focus make sure you don't miss any
areas service you'll end up with patchy
shave and got the Clippers just in case
that's the one thing about these like
Nick you yeah they make you more than
the clothes but you that's the whole
deal once you see first time so yeah it
happens my dad is still getting it
needed part doing it yeah you know shape
your face seems
I don't think so I think you got to get
my back oh yeah see I knew it
I felt it today here just a little bit
but like you said you're reaching around
so it's kind of hard just yeah things
that's walking I think so
so this is the aftershave okay helps
keep your face move keep it from bumping
up dad you know me so just take a little
business just like lotion pretty much
thank you smooching smooching a little
bit so I did cut myself aside a couple
of 1x stinging we go too close to this
dude because that means yeah I think
that's not the only look yeah Nick
that's the only fresh yeah okay you
didn't have to pull your hair back yeah
feel good my face feels fresh and fresh
minty you know cut myself a little bit a
scene in the movie people always got the
little you know tissues all over their
face I didn't even think about it
we've never shaved with a razor before
so it was a new experience biggest thing
was I don't know if I'm cutting him I
don't know if I'm close so if I'm not
far enough I feel good
yeah you feel shaved so smooth like a
baby otter almost my first time I pray
makes you appreciate barbarism and
barbers or doctors almost I like it cool
it's like give me just a vibe I got work
later that's perfect yeah I would
recommend you god I'm not shaving
anytime soon but if I knew someone that
was shave is definitely a lot closer you
know I usually don't go without the
beard but I'm kind of liking the look so
we'll see who knows me maybe I'm being
converted
[Music]
you
[Music]